Oh 2/3 votez monsieur.  dynamite l'
homme le plus travailleur du show business Gulf Father alors
tout le monde m'a dit que je m'amuserais avec n'importe
qui pour faire James Brown quand je
jetais James Brown 20 secondes dedans Je
savais que le brandy Chadwick Boseman était parfait
pour être dans ce film hmm
nous avons vu 42 où il joue Jackie Robinson,
il a une telle noblesse et il apporte cela
à James Brown J'ai dû faire beaucoup
d'introspection avant de l'enlever eh
bien, pour moi, personne ne devrait jouer à
James Brown bébé bébé bébé Le
travail de Chadwick était  le phénoménal
Chad a travaillé son cul, il apparaît
et il le fait vraiment vivre pour vous Je
pense que le défi de ce personnage est
qu'il y a la façon dont il se présente
Nina est qui il est réellement et puis
il y a aussi la façon dont les gens le perçoivent Je suis
juste  un spectacle c'est tout je suis tu pop
bien sûr pas James
Chad la voix qu'il avait le look mais
aussi ce petit bout de paranoïa que
James avait qu'il était
exploité par beaucoup de gens ont
profité de lui et il était très  méfiant  de
cela s'entendre pour le trajet tant que
tout est soigné mais ensuite tu
vas me frapper quand je suis en bas avec tu
penses que je suis en bas parce que la mariée morte n'est
jamais en bas c'était une
transformation parfaite Chadwick est une force pour  être
compté d'
accord fais un angle droit fais le du tout je
parle de jouer à 17 ans un jour 60 le
lendemain je pensais que c'était une
performance magique courageuse mon bébé jouant à
l'âge d'Apollon un bébé
non ils ne sont pas maintenant je veux  tu ne dis à
personne toi ma maman c'est moi tu sais que ce
n'est pas vrai dans sa fascinante et
complexe juste pour voir toute la dynamique de
qui l'homme était exactement appelez-vous votre
musique bien je l'appelle la musique de James
Brown parce que c'est si loin de la sienne  le temps c'est un
homme nous avions de beaux costumes mon DP a fait
un travail formidable et nous avons eu de superbes décors
mais si je suis honnête, tout se résumait
à Chadwick ouais la femme une a vaincu il
était tellement incroyable que la caméra est vraiment
restée sur Chad nous avions  d'autres choses, mais
vous restez sur mr.  Brown c'est la meilleure
chose qu'un homme ait jamais eu